[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  okay i can't believe you using your  tomahawk  it's not tomahawk but isn't it  [Music]  ginormous fingers  [Music]  oh  that's a spoon  [Music]  [Music]  hmm  i  [Music]  much  and then  i got to show you  please  [Music]  um  oops  [Music]  is  so  [Music]  oh  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  is  boys time to clean up look at this mess  boys boys  time to clean up mommy  what did you say to your mother  ah  no i got you now  oh i'm gonna teach you a lesson  if you like this video don't forget to  check out the outdoor boys youtube  channel where we have hundreds of videos  just like this  and don't forget to click subscribe so  you can see other great videos every  saturday morning  and hit that bell button so you'll get  notifications thanks for watching